seeking an abortion in Alabama is
already hard getting through the door of
one of the conservative states few
remaining clinics can be an unpleasant
experience please don't take the life of
your baby ma'am are you making a very
difficult situation a lot harder
well again why is it a difficult
situation ma'am if it's not that this is
not a major no why it's a difficult
situation because you know nothing about
their lives but if they're not taking
the lives their babies and this isn't
and then this isn't a difficult
situation inside the reproductive health
services clinic they've adapted to being
under constant threat in Alabama we've
had an abortion clinic that was bombed
dr. gun was a friend of mine and he was
murdered so the patient goes into the
treatment room we have a I've seen
patients as young as nine I've seen
patients as old as 53 right but incest
today rape and incest and and and women
who were who have been widowed and women
who have been beaten and women who have
nine children and are trying to take
care of those children and women who
have medical conditions and cancer and
in lupus and one kidney the Alabama
Senate has just passed the strictest
abortion law in the country senators
voted to ban all abortions the only
exception if a woman's life is in danger
it's a strategic push to overturn the
landmark 1973 roe v wade ruling which
gives women the right to end a pregnancy
of the 25 male Republicans who voted in
favor of the law senator Dell Marsh is
the only one who agreed to speak to us
about it so this law has no exemption
for rape or incest is that something you
stand by yeah I mean I voted for that
amendment I mean I would have liked to
have seen it on there but it didn't make
it at the end of the day the bill passed
were the only exemption as the health of
the mother so you voted for a law that
if you had a young girl who was raped
she would have to have that child she'd
be forced to have that child you voted
for that what I voted for was a bill to
get to the Supreme Court
talyn's Roe versus Wade that's that's
what the instrument is we understand
that this is not the end game that the
federal courts are going to have to make
a determination what we're trying to do
is force them reconsider that's what
this is all about a wave of anger is
sweeping America the Alabama law is seen
as an increased erosion of women's
reproductive rights he'll come on in
have see most women seeking abortions in
the state are living below the poverty
line this young mother simply can't
afford another child with this new law
this would be a pregnancy that could not
be terminated at three weeks and is
America on the brink of banning abortion
I think Gro was definitely in jeopardy
without a doubt with the supreme court
that we have right now yes the 2020
election is on the horizon these new
abortion laws are setting the battle
lines for a fierce fight Amanda Walker
Sky News Montgomery Alabama